il est 1h du matin
Jessie suit jotting dans son appartement
a-t-il l'intention de la tuer qu'il
commence à se comporter bizarrement
Jessie a le temps d'envoyer un texto à
un ami proche ça sent très très mauvais
ici je veux m'en aller mais elle n'en
aura pas le temps
Hong Kong le quartier de one Shine où ce
côtoie la faune de la nuit et les riches
expatriés de la ville nous sommes avec
Léo le correspondant du journal
britannique The Times
ici on est dans l'un des quartiers
chauds de Hong Kong il y a toutes sortes
de distractions et les prostituées où
ils ont un rôle important c'est pour ça
qu'il y a beaucoup d'expatriés et que
rorrick jetting venait ici
Rory jotting un trader britannique qui a
troqué les salles de marché pour la
rubrique sanglante des faits divers
c'était le 1er novembre dernier en
pleine fête d'Halloween vers 1h du matin
jetting ramène chez lui Jessy une jeune
femme de 29 ans
pour être honnête à cette heure-là
marcher dans la rue avec une jolie
asiatique c'est très commun
personne ne les a remarqué
il habitait ici au 31e étage
c'est là au 31e étage que le trader
aurait égorgé la jeune femme qu'il
venait de faire monter dans son
appartement
dans le quartier les gens faisaient
encore la fête et pendant ce temps-là
dans l'appartement de jeting le meurtre
avait lieu c'était horrible une vraie
boucherie quand la police arrive sur
place elle va faire une autre découverte
tout aussi terrifiante
un deuxième cadavre celui de Lise 23 ans
ils ont retrouvé ce corps dans une
valise sur le balcon
c'était apparemment une fille qu'il
connaissait bien
qui a appelé la police il a
immédiatement été placé en détention
Hong Kong sous le choc la ville à l'un
des taux de criminalité les plus bas du
monde
ici on n'est pas habitué aux faits
divers
qui est Rory John comment ce trader
richissime en est-il arrivé là
son histoire commence à chartsey en
Angleterre une petite ville de 15000
habitants dans la banlieue de Londres
c'est ici que Rory a passé une enfance
choyée il vivait avec ses parents et son
frère dans cette grande maison de deux
étages
le week-end la famille de jeting avait
pour habitude d'aller fouiner dans ce
magasin d'antiquités
Maurine la propriétaire les a très bien
connus
bien sûr je me souviens très bien d'eux
c'était une famille adorable
qu'est-ce que je pourrais dire d'autre
c'était juste des gens gentils
je le voyais seulement de temps en temps
car il vivait en pensionnat mais c'était
un garçon gentil mignon sincère et bien
éduqué
un gamin bien sous tout rapport et
brillant élève en plus il obtient une
bourse de 40000 euros pour aller étudier
au très chic collège de Winchester
veste et cravate obligatoire une tenue
qu'il portera toute sa vie
[Musique]
plus tard il intègre la prestigieuse
université de Cambridge il pratique même
l'aviron et devient l'un des meilleurs
membres du club de son école
douée pour les études sportif le voilà
promis au plus bel avenir
[Musique]
mais devenu adulte Rick change comme
l’explique Ben Rossington un journaliste
du Daily Mirror qui a enquêté sur son
passé
avec un diplôme de Cambridge vous
appartenez à l'élite et il ressentait le
pouvoir que cela lui donnait et
logiquement il s'est dirigé vers la
banque qui est le symbole de la
puissance ou le seul but est de faire de
l'argent
il décroche un premier poste de trader à
Londres dans une banque de la City
à cette époque il a déjà tous les atouts
de la réussite
il a déjà eu plusieurs petites amies
dont Sonia une jeune mannequin aucune ne
s'est plaint de comportements déviants
de sa part
en juillet 2013 Rory juting s'installa
Hong Kong
il est recruté par Meryl Lynch l'une des
plus importantes banques
d'investissement au monde il travaille
au 42e étage de cette tour dans le
quartier des affaires il gagne beaucoup
d'argent environ 50 000 euros par mois
[Musique]
le banquier loue un appartement dans cet
immeuble de standing avec piscine
solarium et salle de sport privé aux
derniers étages
jotting n'a pas beaucoup d'amis c'est un
solitaire dans la vie il n'a qu'une
obsession l'argent
ça le rendait dingue et forcément cela
influencé sa vie il prenait les gens de
haut ils se sentait plus important que
ce qui peut expliquer son attirance pour
les prostituées
le soir il se met à fréquenter les bars
et les filles du quartier chaud de one
Shine à 5 minutes à pied de chez lui
[Musique]
il traîne notamment dans le bar de
Robert Vandenbosch qui se souvient très
bien de lui
on l'appelait Ricky c'était son surnom
ici il était un peu grossier un peu
arrogant il se voyait lui-même comme une
personne très importante car il gagnait
beaucoup d'argent c'était un bon
banquier il avait une très haute opinion
de lui-même
mais Ricky était respectueux c'était un
bon client
il était toujours gentil avec les filles
de toute façon s'il ne l'était pas
aucune fille ne l'aurait suivi il les
traitait bien il leur payait des vers et
leur donner de l'argent quand elles
étaient avec lui ce qui s'est passé a
été un vrai choc personne ne pensait
qu'une telle chose pouvait arriver
ce week-end Ricky les passe avec des
prostituées elles ont toutes le même
profil de jeunes asiatiques jolies sexy
comme les tests et deux victimes
pendant un an Rorik dépense sans compter
il boit beaucoup d'ailleurs il a pris du
poids jusqu'au jour où il semble perdre
la tête
est-il animé de pulsions morbides quand
il rencontre Jessie cette fameuse nuit
d'Halloween à deux pas du bar de Robert
[Musique]
vers 8 9 heures du soir j'ai vu Jessie
devant notre bar elle m'a dit bonjour
Avec son éternel bonne humeur
elle m'a donné deux bises et ensuite
elle m'a dit Daddy je vais bien m'amuser
cette nuit je vais au New Makati pour la
fête d'Halloween
c'était ces derniers mots je les entend
encore
le New macati c'est dans cette
discothèque qu'elle va rencontrer la
mort que s'est-il passé ensuite il est
une heure du matin
Jessy suit jotting dans son appartement
a-t-il l'intention de la tuer ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il commence à se comporter
bizarrement peut-être devient-il violent
Jessy a le temps d'envoyer un texto à un
ami proche
ça sent très très mauvais ici je veux
m'en aller
mais elle n'en aura pas le temps
jetting aurait alors saisi un coup d’eau
de cuisine et égorgé la jeune femme
le trader aurait ensuite pris des photos
du cadavre avant d'appeler la police
[Musique]
vers 3h30 du matin c'est lui qui leur
ouvre la porte il est dans un état
second
dans le salon les policiers découvrent
Jessie gisant par terre agonisante elle
mourra quelques instants plus tard les
enquêteurs sont intrigués par une odeur
pestilentielle la même qui avait
incommodée Jessy sur le balcon il trouve
une valise à l'intérieur le Coran
décomposition d'une jeune indonésienne
de 23 ans lise massacré 5 jours plus tôt
dans le village où elle est née en
Indonésie sa famille est sous le choc
son père réclame la tête du meurtrier
il a tué ma fille je veux qu'il soit
condamné à mort c'est tout ce qu'il
mérite
lise et Jessie postaient beaucoup de
photos d'elle sur leur compte facebook
jeune et pleine de vie
Robert ne se remet toujours pas de la
disparition de son ami Jessie
c'était vraiment une personne très bien
qui avait beaucoup de cœur
elle va beaucoup nous manquer
elle habitait ici au 9e étage ces filles
vivaient jusqu'à 6 dans un seul
appartement comme ça ça leur revenait à
100 euros par personne
comme des milliers de leurs compatriotes
elles étaient venus à Hong Kong
travailler comme domestiques mais elles
ont vite déchanter sous-payés maltraités
les deux jeunes filles ont été obligés
de trouver de l'argent autrement
si tu travailles ici comme employé de
maison tu peux te faire entre 4 et 500
euros par mois si tu travailles dans le
milieu de la nuit tu peux doubler voire
tripler ton salaire
Robert n'osent pas le dire mais c'est
comme ça que Jessy Élise sont tombés
dans la prostitution et plus tard dans
les griffes du trader une vie de misère
à des années-lumière de l'opulence dans
laquelle vivait jotting
dans ce foyer ENI recueille de jeunes
indonésiennes au bord de la rupture
comme Jessie Élise c'est elle qui s'est
occupée du rapatriement de leur corps
là
il y avait beaucoup de monde
ENI se bat maintenant pour que justice
soit rendue aux deux victimes et pour
que leurs proches soient indemnisés car
lise et Jessie faisait vivre leur
famille dans leur pays natal
et sa famille et elle a même dit à sa
meilleure amie qu'elle avait l'intention
de rentrer très vite chez elle une fois
la maison terminée
comment jeting en est-il arrivé à de
telles extrémités
[Musique]
les enquêteurs ont découvert qu'il avait
posté un message énigmatique sur son
compte facebook le jour même du premier
meurtre
se lancer dans le vide
plus de fardeau un nouveau voyage
commence je suis effrayé mais excité
aussi le premier pas est toujours le
plus dur
le premier pas pour une nouvelle vie ou
pour le premier meurtre il y a un indice
cependant la police se rend compte que
sa vie professionnelle bascule à la même
période en fait sa licence de trader a
été révoquée pour quelle raison la
banque reste silencieuse jetting se
retrouve sans emploi et c'est à ce
moment-là que ses collègues de travail
reçoivent ce message qui fait froid dans
le dos
je suis parti du bureau indéfiniment
pour toute requête urgente merci de
contacter quelqu'un qui n'est pas un
psychopathe
pour aller plus loin merci de contacter
Dieu même si je soupçonne qu'il faudra
plutôt contacter le diable
[Musique]
il finit avec ses parenthèse
ce message ne sera valable que si j'ai
mené à bien mon projet
quand on voit les mots qui l'utilisent
on se rend compte qu'il n'est pas dans
un état normal qu'il n'est pas bien dans
sa tête c'est comme si il avait fait un
bras d'honneur à la banque en disant je
m'en vais
on ne peut que supposer qu'il subissait
une énorme pression
la justice elle se demande si le trader
n'est pas devenu fou et on peut se poser
la question en le voyant arriver dans le
fourgon qui le conduit au tribunal
il ricane
devant ses juges il a la même attitude
désinvolte nous avons réussi à le filmer
en caméra discrète ce sont les seules
images de lui à l'intérieur du tribunal
il n'a pas l'air de comprendre ce qui
lui arrive
mais après deux semaines d'expertise
psychiatrique la Cour a déclaré qu'il
était responsable de ses actes
son procès aura lieu l'été prochain Rory
jetting risque la prison à vie